what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel and feel free to
subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
all right so as we continue with Excel
Manowar this is actually a pretty cool
issue or I guess a pretty cool story
with regards to planet death and the
reason why is because I kind of bring to
this first story arc so to speak with X
I'm an award that Tibet actually
initiates a whole new store which is
really kind of cool it brings them the
conflict with unity and that kind of
thing but initially we start off here
with the origin of the exo-armor and
this is kind of a cool story because
what this does is it sort of relies on
this creation myth right I mean every
society has some kind of a creation
method we have here on earth everywhere
from like the Bashan go people in
central Africa at least according to a
Stephen Hawking lecture anyway all the
way up to you know the creation myths of
judeo-christianity and that kind of
thing and so it creates these really
really cool situations because again
that really prides itself on the notion
of taking real world elements and
throwing them into comic books and what
we find out is that on this vine world
on loan that at one point on the line
this world was very lush and was very
peaceful and the people themselves were
peaceful to bind themselves were a
peaceful race but somewhere along the
line they were visited by a race called
the torment now again you know Venditti
does not give us the origin of the
torment in fact we really don't need to
hear the reason being because of the
fact that much like the vine we're kind
of given this perspective that no one
knows where the torment came from they
were just there one day but they
essentially just kind of fed off the the
anguish and the pain of the vine race
themselves as they basically forced the
vine to terraform their planet to tear
down everything that they had built or
at least another planet were presented
in terms of he's fearing race now again
because of the fact that those four men
had sworn everything down at least at
some point along the line a simple like
a single member of the vine race had
stumbled across a tree the last of this
great tree odd that had existed it was
called the Hara tree and from this Hara
tree came a single item basically the
exo-armor the armor was donned by this
one particular member of the vine race
and using the horsepower the vine race
in turn basically cast out the torment
and then began a new era sort of
starting things anew and again that's
why this works kind of cool because this
isn't designed to be like this super
in-depth explanation this design it just
kind of be like is it true or is it
false a really good example of this
again kind of referencing this Stephen
Hawking lecture is at one point in human
history like the philosopher Aristotle
believed that like rivers streams
mountains that they were constant
backdrops because those things that were
change over the course of a human life
like you will not see Mount Everest
crumble and then come back over the
course of your lifetime if it does then
one either the earth is going through a
catastrophic change or - like you're
immortal so because of that you know
Aristotle believed that you know
humanity's depiction of progress but is
basically because of tact like natural
disasters would wipe out or would Lisa
at least would suck the human race back
to the beginning I mean it was just a
constant cycle that we would progress to
a future point and then we will be wiped
out it would be pushing the brink of
extinction and we would start over again
now we know that's not the case just by
way of the fact that there's massive
buildings things like that that if
humanity was pushed to the brink of
extinction and had to start over again
we would find relics of advanced human
human designs somewhere along the line
but a Kris is really cool an interesting
situation at the same time if I were to
come to you and I were to say you know
like humanity as we exist right now this
is our third incarnation that we started
off on a planet on the other side of the
universe
we basically waged war it led to our
destruction and now we're just you know
for however many decades we spend time
basically traversing the spaceways until
we found a new home we've discovered
this earth we mingled ourselves with
early humanity and here we are that's
the plot to Battlestar Galactica if I
were to tell that to you there'd be no
way for you to refute that as being true
you would be like well my guess is
possible and that's the cool thing about
this you know what these creation myths
is they basically just rely on the
notion of faith now again all this is
being told by way of the particular
priest that we've been seeing this
entire time but in the middle of this
lecture of him basically speaking to his
followers were met with the arrival of
Aaron this is the coolest part about
this for this is what I love this so
much it's because remember Eric is here
is a man on a mission
like he's pissed off you know the vine
had captured him taking him from his
home on earth they had basically
traveled him around with spaceways for
2,000 years using the speed of light in
order to make it seem like time didn't
pass as fast as his hat he came back to
earth discovered everything he knew and
loved was gone the vine came after him
because he took the exo-armor and they
intended to wipe out all of humanity
what Eric is doing here is coming back
and basically saying I'm going to kill
you I'm going to annihilate all of you
before you annihilate me and now of
course he goes through a kill almost
every single one of these priests except
for the head priest the one that we've
seen throughout the entire story and the
cool thing is that this head priest
basically says look you know I'm not
like the others you know I consider the
Sean Haugh armor to be a design prophecy
the armor chooses the person who wields
it and so because of that this priest
says if Sean Hara shows you then unlike
the others of Y ratio these members of
the military who want to see it
weaponized and used by the vine
I accept Sean Horace divine judgment now
the funny thing about this is Eric looks
at businesses now I don't believe you
one bit I think you're telling me what I
want to hear in order to say a lot as
though the intention of Erika's to kill
this guy but again his arrival was
noticed by the vibrations themselves by
the military and of course they respond
before Eric's able to kill this priest
but again with the external armor
because of its capabilities because of
how powerful it is you know it basically
allows Eric to lay waste to all these
different forces and in response to this
he's taken by the priests to what's left
or at least what seems to be left of
these difficult people this is how we
learned how deep this goes
that prior to this point all we knew was
that the Visigoths on earth and whatever
Romans happened to be captured and so on
and so forth they were all taken aboard
the colony ship and they were just
travel yet just travel around the
spaceways being used as really just as
workers to tend to their fields and so
on and so forth what we didn't know was
that some of these individuals had been
taken back to loam back to the vine
homeworld now this is really significant
for Eric and the reason why is because
when he gets here he finds a woman who's
wearing a cloth that belongs to a member
of the Visigoths and because of the fact
that it belonged to his uncle and
because the woman who's wearing it bears
a striking resemblance to his wife Dedra
his initial thought is that he's found
his wife because remember this stands to
reason
you know if being on the auto colony
ship meant that Eric himself could be
alive he's trusting his hope and
believing that those individuals on the
loam home world would still be alive now
we know that's not the case right we
know that like time passes normally on
the loam loam homeworld in the same way
it does on earth and so this girl is
generations down the line from the
people that Eric knew I mean the
ancestors he knew the the friends and
family that he had even if they were
brought to the to the vine homeworld
they would be dead they would long be
dead by you know thousands of years and
so because of this the idea here is that
on behalf of Eric because he's looking
at all these members who are basically
descendants of the Visigoths race as
well as all these other races who have
been captured by the vine and in place
on their homeworld as slave labor the
actions or at least the response of Eric
is to basically go and free every last
one of them now of course from here
we're set upon by the special forces you
know Erica is set upon by the special
forces of the vine and that's what's
also kind of interesting with this
situation is because remember the whole
concept of the exo-armor is seen in
different ways where the priests look at
it is something divine they look at it
as the armor having a life of its own
you are more choosing who it is that
wields it and those individuals
basically worshipping the individual who
wields it as a god the military looks at
it as a weapon so like we can weaponize
this we can allow one of our members of
the vine race to use this and if they
can successfully wield this suit then
they can be a soldier for us they can be
a harbinger of our ability to basically
go through and conquer various races now
of course in response to this Eric seems
to be defeated by these special forces
of the vine and the armor basically
leaves him and basically you know just
kind of takes off it goes back to
essentially heal itself but in the midst
of this eric is rescued by a member of
the vine now this is where we start to
get a lot of exposition here we get sort
of get a lot of explanation a lot of you
guys who are kind of wondering what
direction things were going in how all
this comes together this is where we get
that eric is basically when he's brought
back by this by this you know random
soldier that essentially saves his life
he's given the whole explanation here
that as far as the priest is concerned
again because of the fact that Devine
wanted to weaponize this armor that
multiple members of the vine race really
their best soldiers would always try to
put the armor on but whenever they did
it would basically kill them it would
scramble their brains destroy their
minds and that would be the end of them
they would basically died and so what
had been happening is much like the
sword in the stone divine military had
been sending their best soldiers to try
on this suit of armor under the idea
that this singular individual who first
used the armor to cast off the torment
would be born again that they were
basically
relive this entire experience now the
reason why this matters is because while
the military doesn't really look at the
armor of Xiong Hara as divine they still
derive their beliefs
from the faith aspect of it in the sense
of the military believes that they are
inherently destined to wield this armor
because the first person the wielded was
a member of their race and so because of
that they look at this and say it's our
design divine prophecy it's the divine
prophecy of the vine race to use this
armor and when that happens we will take
it for whatever purpose we deem I mean
who knows what they would do conquer
planets whatever the case may be the
other concept the other concept that
we're given here is again we're told
that there are a multitude of different
races that have all been conquered by
divine themselves and because of that
Eric's goal is to again dawn the armor
and free all these different races now
in the middle of all this because of the
fact that divine look at Eric as what he
represents from the symphony represents
hope he represents the ability to escape
by breaking the spirits of those
individuals around him they can kill
Eric and then wipe out everybody else
and essentially call it a day the
problem with this is that when they send
their best soldiers out yet again the
armor begins to heal itself Eric calls
to it and because of fact they share
so to speak or they share a connection
the armor ends up bonding itself to Eric
of a Fiat yet again now this is really
cool here because this is rubber
Venditti basically saying the two are
inseparable the armor chose Eric Eric
chose the armor the accepted one another
they don't they they kind of have this
symbiotic relationship in the sense that
the armor sort of shares itself with
Eric Eric shares of stuff for the armor
but you are essentially one in the same
now it's like Thor recalling his own
hammer and because of that when Eric
goes out and faces off against all these
special forces these leaders these
people who are watching this conflict on
folks who are watching their forces
decimated quick fast and in a hurry they
start to have a change of heart they're
like maybe the legends are true
maybe the stories about this armor being
divine or true maybe if the armor chose
this guy it chose him for a reason maybe
it's not our place to question the
decisions of the armor itself and that's
a cool thing because now they're
starting to be the sort of resurgence
this insurgents against the ruling class
in the planet of lone it's kind of cool
to see this unfold because it's always
this idea that everything seems to come
around full circle that even if Eric
basically wanted to bring down the vine
around him he basically does it
indirectly well he was one we want to
Niall ate the entirety of the vine race
all we had to do was appear here and
give people a reason to believe that he
is inherently divine give people a
reason to believe that the armor is
divine and chose him and he can
basically defeat the entirety of the
vine race by sending the vine race into
a civil war
in and of itself and that's exactly what
happens the leader of all these forces
you know general actual comes back to
the to the council and says look I have
seen the power of this armor I I watched
our Special Forces
I'm nyle aided by this armor as if they
were nothing they were just incinerated
with the greatest of ease perhaps this
priest speaks the truth
perhaps this priest is telling the truth
when he says this armor is divine and
even the general himself says even if
even if the council doesn't believe that
the yummers divine the general himself
does he says I look at this armor and I
see something divine and I will not wage
war against a god and so in response to
this the council takes it out the
council's like fine if you will not
attack this armor then we will and this
is when we learn how deep the council
goes that's a cool thing about this
because Venditti gives us this race call
divine right Amin says hey look here's
this extra dimensional race they're very
human in their regard there are
fundamental aspects of humanity of all
races that are that are similar just as
much as they are unique the unique
properties of the line is how they look
their ability to traverse the space wave
interstellar travel things like that but
the common
separate wean this vine weighs in
humanity is that these individuals will
hold on to a power as long as they can
and we see that in a lot of different
facets we see that with individual
people the woman who runs the PTA and
just refuses to not be President she'll
go as far as to cheat to make sure that
she's still running the show members of
the government who will cheat who will
engage in corruption who will see out
assassinations in order to make sure
that they stay in power it's always the
same story absolute power corrupts
absolutely and because of that these are
members of the vine councils are willing
to obliterate the entirety of the planet
using it using a satellite array wipe
out all life on the planet and then
travel to a new planet and start again
if it means that they will be able to
keep the legacy going if it means
they'll be able to keep their power and
keep their race a lot though this kind
of begs an interesting question you wake
up one morning and the curtains are gone
and the paint's peeling and the water's
boiling what do you do well some people
will say well you try to figure out why
the water's boiling you try to figure
out why the paintsville you try to
figure out what's going on no you get
out of the house because your house is
burning down and that's what seems to be
happening here is a really cool
situation where man did he says these
council members aren't necessarily
inherently evil they're getting while
the gettin's good and it creates a
really cool situation because it like
it's left to us to decide which one we
think is right which is which one do we
fly with do we tie with the fact that
these guys are inherently evil I mean
they are you know but it's like do we
side with the faculties are inherently
bad guys or do we sign with the fact
that they just want to see their race
continue going on because of their
actions and going around the universe
capturing different races using them for
you know as a labor force are they good
guys or are they bad guys are they
following their own nature it was
self-preservation or are they basically
you know bound by corruption and they
want to live on for the sole purpose of
just seeing themselves kept a lot they
create some really interesting
situations here but again because of the
fact that eric is basically able to take
out all these different members of the
of the vine council because he appears
to all the forces of the vine race and
says the divine armor of Shana Hara has
chosen me either you can believe that or
you can face death they all basically
actually yes the priest you know goes on
to tell everybody our day has come you
know we have not been Forsaken our day
of devotion has been rewarded the armor
has chosen a person to wield it our God
has come back he may not be with us the
entire time but our God has basically
come back and so what does does it this
basically leads to the remove
of the military fashion of the bond
society instead what it does is it
basically leaves the planet with some
measure of peace it leaves the planet
with some measure of normalcy and so
again we basically end up travelling I
guess picking up with Erik as he and a
multitude of these guys all travel back
to earth so basically kind of initiate
what will will be tantamount to Erik
showing up on earth and re-establishing
Visigoth basically incurring the wrath
of your superheroes and initiating the
unity story arc but with that being said
guys we're going to bring this video to
an end if you're new here to come as
explained make sure you guys have the
sub video sub button to become part of
the Rob course you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and yeah
I'll catch you all in it
[Music]